if they can't declare war on iran
republicans can at least move forward
with their war on women yes they're
taking the debate on reproductive rights
back a good 50 years while each of the
Republican presidential candidates tries
to stand out from the other 16 and
counting the one thing they all agree on
is that stopping abortion is a top
priority I'm completely pro-life I hate
the concept of abortion all human life
at every stage of its development is
worthy of protection I believe that that
is an unborn child it's in need of
protection out there Wow you know what's
so clear none of these candidates has
ever had an abortion candidates have
been tripping over each other to condemn
Planned Parenthood over a video that
surfaced revealing the organization
donates fetal tissue to medical research
change the policy to be pro-life and
protect children instead of rip up their
body parts and sell them like they're
parts to a Buick ripping up body parts
no Planned Parenthood has said that at
the woman's request they donate fetal
tissue not organs or body parts to help
with vaccines and to cure diseases like
Parkinson's Planned Parenthood has also
said that the money they receive is only
to pay for transportation and storage
costs still all candidates are now
saying government money to Planned
Parenthood should be cut off absolutely
we need a defund Planned Parenthood
something governor Scott Walker and Jeb
Bush have previously done in their
respective states Scott Walker also just
signed one of the most restrictive
abortion bills in the nation it
prohibits abortion after 20 weeks in all
cases even in the case of rape and
incest for some conservative context the
three prior Republican presidential
candidates all back to the rape and
incest exemption and as president george
w bush kept funding for fetal tissue
research but who cares in light of the
recent fetal tissue uproar Governor
Bobby Jindal of Louisiana pulled Planned
Parenthood from Medicaid funding even
though the states to Planned Parenthood
centers don't provide abortion and Texas
senator Ted Cruz has threatened a
government shutdown if federal funds to
Planned Parenthood aren't stopped all
this fetal mongering actually managed to
make Senator Lindsey Graham appear
moderate both he and Jeb Bush said that
as president they would divert federal
Planned Parenthood money to other
women's health clinics let's take the
money that we would give to Planned
Parenthood and put it in women's health
care but here's the deal Lindsay Planned
Parenthood is about women's health an
abortion only makes up three percent of
its services most of the organization's
work is on STD treatment and
contraceptive services to you know
prevent the need for abortions on the
other side of the aisle Hillary Clinton
tweeted during the debate if the GOP
attacks on Planned Parenthood feel like
an assault on women's health it's
because they are and Bernie Sanders
tweeted does any do you appear care
whether or not a woman rather than the
government should be making decisions
about her own body good question burn
good question